a team player a good work ethic some of
the basic skills listed in job
descriptions but increasingly employers
are looking for candidates with good IT
skills and social media awareness a
win-win situation for the new tech savvy
generation but with twenty one percent
of young Europeans without a job it
would seem that they are hard to place
in the market Sienna strone plaza dr
otaku yamato mode a platonic of trento
do ray communicative no-see Alice do
estrone tenon modem modem the transit of
possible dholna communica- impossible to
editor John exactly Anya seven million
people aged between 15 to 24 years old
aren't just unemployed they're not in
training or education there is a skills
mismatch between what young people
experience in their daily lives and
maybe what's actually needed in the
workplace and that therefore we need to
we need to fit those two things together
but it's not only about IT skills it's
also about the sort of the softer skills
how do you actually work with other
people MEP is want to focus on real
partnership with SMEs and have better
matchup theoretical education with
training disadvantaged groups like voted
disability or from lower income families
would be given social skills training
but this attempt to invigorate the jobs
debate depends on whether the EU
Commission will now act provide conquer
legislation to help the Lost Generation